sobbing crying an emotional punch to the
heart keep watching to find out why
every Marvel fan is tearing up about the
latest MCU mid-credit scene at this
point releasing an MCU film without
including either a mid-credit or end
credit scene would be like Marvel
Cinematic blasphemy fans love them and
the internet is full of listicles trying
to rank them from worst to best but what
makes for a good post-movie credit scene
sometimes it's as simple as a bunch of
superheroes sitting together eating
Shawarma after saving New York from
total Destruction other scenes are
memorable and impactful because they
foreshadow great things to come like
Nick Fury at the end of Iron Man
thanos's big reveal also at the end of
The Avengers or Nick Fury's pager
signaling the arrival of Captain Marvel
at the end of Avengers Infinity War so
how does the mid-credits scene from
Black Panther wakanda forever stack up
against the movies that came before it
well if these social media response is
any indication this scene hit a home run
right out of the park not only did it
answer a nagging question which fans
have been wondering about for years but
it did so in an emotionally satisfying
way that has now emptied the tear ducts
of millions of moviegoers Nationwide be
warned Major Spoilers ahead one viral
tweet accompanying a gif of an adorable
black and white cat with watery eyes
seemingly trying to cover its face with
a splayed paw reads me the whole time
during the post credits of black panther
wakanda forever the Tweet perfectly
captures the emotional impact the film
has had on moviegoers there seems to be
an even mix of people in the replies
expressing similar sentiments with gifs
of animals or famous people crying
messages of solidarity or both another
Twitter user admitted I thought I was
done crying then the post-credit scene
punched me in the heart while yet
another user chose to go with a simple
quote for real and an attached GIF of
Tyrese with tears rolling down his
cheeks Talk of the scene begins
spreading across Reddit too and this
spoiler-friendly discussion thread a
Reddit user thought that the final scene
followed by the credits were so good it
really tied the whole thing together
that's such a wild thing to say but holy
it got me choked up Sim similarly
another redditor felt the most emotional
scene to me was shuri in Haiti my
theater was dead silent like it stole
every breath cue Rihanna Lift Me Up
beautiful it's certainly one thing to
create an emotionally impactful scene in
a popular film like this one but when
you add in the group experience of
seeing it in a theater the emotions of
everyone in the room only compound the
effect for the audience this mid-credit
scene reveals a big secret that Marvel
has been sitting on since Avengers end
game came out in 2019 and that secret is
King t'challa has a son the young boy is
seen with his mother Nakia who we now
know is Alive and Well post blib she
explains to shuri that they settled in
Haiti to raise the future king of
wakanda away from the stress of the
crown and if the young man grows up to
be as grounded as his father it will
have been a smart move as much of a
surprise as the Revelation was to most
audience members at least one attentive
Marvel fan saw this big reveal coming a
mile away one of the replies to that
Viral tweet mentioned earlier was one
from a Twitter user who pointed out they
predicted that the sequel would more
than likely introduce t'challa's son at
some point aptly pointing out that
before the film's release MCU fans still
had no idea whether Nakia survived the
snap they may not have predicted that it
would end up in the mid credits or how
emotionally impactful it would be but
they at least deserve a little credit
for calling it ahead of time
[Music]